time for a change that's the mantra
following the 2021 german election the
medical era is ending the parties hoping
to form the next government promised to
make this country fit for the future but
to those whose future hangs in the
balance believe them
what does the election result mean for
the generation under 30. how do young
people see the coalition maneuvering
that's now getting underway their lives
have been deeply impacted by the
pandemic's effects on schools and the
economy their futures will be profoundly
shaped by the next government's answer
to the climate crisis do they feel they
have a voice
our topic youth vote how much change
does germany need
[Music]
[Music]
and it's a great pleasure to welcome our
guests ragida banam is a freelance
journalist with family ties to lebanon
and she says germany has an opportunity
under an sple-led government to be more
inclusive of people with migration
background
it's also a pleasure to welcome valerie
herna she's an editor of the german news
magazine de spiegel and her opening
statement is young people in germany
have shaped the debate about climate
change any coalition will have to answer
to them
and i'm very pleased to welcome our
colleague from dw he's a political
correspondent in our uh our berlin
bureau benjamin alvarez and he thinks
germany's aging population is impeding
real political change even though young
voters are a minority their concerns
should be taken more
seriously
so let me ask all of you now that german
voters have had their say what your take
is on the result thumbs up or thumbs
down and uh if i look at your opening
statement uh regida it sounds like
you're pretty optimistic uh well
benjamin is skeptical and valerie i'm
not quite sure so let me just go
straight uh around the table please
fragida thumbs up or thumbs thumbs up or
thumbs down well i think it is
optimistic to be honest because it's i
mean it's the first time we see that
there isn't any more two big parties
that are taking everything and then
forming a government with a small junior
partner now i mean we're going to see
for the first time ever in germany that
there will be three partners in the
coalition and the main partner has only
taken approximately 25 percent of the
votes so they will be leading but they
will be leading taken into consideration
uh the other two parties which
i'm assuming will be the greens and the
liberals and the greens most essentially
will be an important partner because
i think the way also the results came
and the two big parties did not win
enough votes over the threshold of 30
is because of the green and all what the
greens represented from the climate
change fighting the climate change and
all that uh the two big parties could
not um maybe bring all all this on the
agenda as much as they should have so a
lot of those votes went to the greens
instead
and then the two big parties had to
implement this in their agenda and their
manifestos and they ended up winning but
not you know fully
what do you mean
you're right melinda i'm skeptical but i
would lean two thumbs up because it's
the end of an era and end of an era
always means there's possibility for
change and now with coalition talks and
new parties gaining a lot of ground i
think it's a possibility also for
younger voters and their ideas also to
make it into the political debate let me
ask you did anything particularly
surprise you about the election results
i would say in general that a lot of
young people not only voted for the
greens but also for the business ftp
that was quite surprising for me i'm
sure we'll talk about that later we're
definitely going to unpack that result a
little bit later valerie where do you
stand uh thumbs up thumbs down or
somewhere in the middle uh well i think
for me the the
best thing about this election result
was that um it showed that the election
was one in the middle uh so the ftp the
green party um the city or the nyun and
the spd they all had you know gains and
shifts but the afd essentially lost a
little bit
and um
so i thought that that was great
and not only the fd afd but also the uh
left wing party right the left party
also also lost so it really came back to
the middle a little bit more but then it
spread out within the middle which i
think is really interesting and i agree
it can be sort of an opportunity a
catalyst for maybe change um that has to
happen but also it's still in the middle
so it's you know it's not it's not a
radical it's not going to be a totally
radical revolution that we're gonna see
now i don't think the green party wants
that i don't think the spd wants that
none of the parties want that so i think
it's a good sign for our democracy that
people felt they could vote for parties
of the middle
and still
and that those parties represented what
they wanted to change in the country can
i just ask you um when you talk to
young german friends and colleagues do
they feel that their voices were heard
by the parties that were contending in
this election i think i think that
mostly they did
some of my friends especially my younger
friends they're they are quite
politicized um and they're active for
the green party or the spd or
um
but um so i have like you know it's a
wide variety sort of of standpoints but
they all feel that they were heard and i
think more so than past elections so i
think especially the green party taking
on this more significant role within the
party system has led to that but also
um also the spd sort of coming from this
you know they were absolutely shattered
a few years ago right and so they've
they've sort of reestablished themselves
and the you azuz the young social
democrats also played a big role in that
and i think that was very important for
me come back we'll come back to that as
well in a moment but let's take a closer
listen to young people's voices nearly
three million people voted for the first
time in last weekend's vote many of them
were in kindergarten when angela merkel
took over the helm of germany 16 years
ago we went to leipzig to meet two young
first-time voters
i think the federal election was
ordinary i just hope that we get a
stable government and don't have a new
chancellor every few months like in
italy but that we have something that's
actually stable
it's just not quite clear which
government coalition it will be now and
whether it's really as progressive as
people wished for in the run-up to the
election
i'm not that worried about it with a
stronger presence from the green party
and a strong fdp
and a relatively weakened cdu and spd
the issues that concern the smaller
coalition partners can also be at the
top of the agenda
having a strategy in place for climate
protection instead of just objectives
what will pensions look like in 30 40
years how will all of that work that was
the big question for me
that was super important for my voting
decision
merkel's departure after 16 years means
managing the next four years without her
for the first time and i think that will
be difficult
so perhaps a little bit of
of a sense of missing angela merkel
there at the end in fact
angela merkel is the only chancellor who
many first-time voters can remember
will they miss her will you miss her
well i'm not that young but
it's interesting because i also heard
that someone that young was asking can a
man actually be a chancellor of germany
because angela merkel has really taken
the memory of all those young voters for
the first time
and she was such a powerful leader and
and she reigned uh again over 16 years
of stability in germany that for a lot
of people now it's really worrying
what's going to happen now that angela
merkel is not in power anymore would we
not see the stability keep going on and
it was interesting that also the two
main candidates amir lachet and olaf
schultz they both try to represent
themselves as they're going to be the
continuity for angered america and
they're going to keep the country stable
uh even without her i mean we all
remember how schultz you know being from
the espadin or even the city which also
wrote
you can be a chancellor cancel green and
and you know as a feminine female so
it's it's interesting that this sense of
stability has you know
has stayed throughout michael's years
and now you know people are wondering
are we going to stay a stable country
without money let me ask you about
another aspect of that because your
opening statement did mention diversity
and inclusion of course it was angela
merkel who made the decision to open the
doors and let in a million refugees
are you confident that you you seem
optimistic about diversity going forward
but are you confident that there will be
that kind of a commitment uh from other
politicians i'm not confident i'm
hopeful
uh because well i'm hopeful also if it
was an espd-led coalition not a city
oullet coalition because merkel was
something of a she was not the city oh
and now after merkel
left they said it was going to be a
totally different party and actually a
lot of refugees who came senior refugees
who came in 2015 uh voted for the ones
who were allowed to vote voted for
michael to you know or you know their
families who were here before them but
now they're not as hopeful after america
left and now they're switching to other
parties to the espd mainly or the greens
because they are more they have much
more welcoming refugee culture
she did not go as far as introducing
laws to
properly integrate the refugees uh in
terms of maybe dual nationality or in
terms of
even degrees that they could you know
work with immediately without having to
spend years trying to convert them and
be able to work in germany
so that's why i said i was hopeful
ben you mean mackel herself was a gifted
juggler if you will in the political
circus keeping numerous balls in the air
and certainly earning great respect
amongst amongst many people both abroad
and here at home is there another
politician currently active in germany
who has those kind of political skills
and foreign policy acumen i don't think
so and especially what you just said i
think that's very interesting angela
merkel is not the cdu and a lot of
people who don't like what the cdu is
doing or don't like these conservative
ideas
see don't criticize her for that i mean
they see us for the human part when we
look at this picture and you have a
leader who's leaving after 16 years
who's taking pictures you know with
parrots
leaving and you can imagine her you know
going back to a really really normal
life after 16 years it's incredible if
you compare it to other world leaders
or in other regions in latin america if
we had someone for 16 years i'm sure he
would have you know try to grab his way
try to move something in there and
if you have someone like that for 16
years staying true to herself that's
pretty remarkable and i don't think
anyone in her party can get into those
big footsteps i was looking at some
surveys of the international press and
they all mentioned her modesty and
incorruptability as one of the key
traits that made her so popular abroad
valerie the young people in our report
that we just saw clearly think that
germany's political landscape will be
less stable and predictable in future
than it has been in the past
what would you say are they right and is
that a good thing or a bad one well they
framed it to be a bad thing but i don't
think it has to be a bad thing i think
it can be interesting if the political
system if
that's why i said in the beginning that
it was so important that these elections
were one in the middle because they were
one in the middle so democracy is not at
stake here it's not like like a
situation we had in the u.s in 2016 or
something like that there's no
you know it's it's not going to be a
radical change like that so i think
having a little less stability is
actually good for democracy good for the
discussions good for the debate
especially also in parliament maybe
we'll see the debates in parliament
actually taking more center stage which
i think would be great um so i i don't
see it i'm i'm very optimistic about
about the future at this point so a lot
of people in the cdu at this moment are
less optimistic because they had their
historic
worst result and you could say that this
election appears to mark not just the
end of the medical era but also the end
of the big tent parties the sbd has been
seeing its share of the vote shrink for
more than a decade and now the cdu
appears to be in the same vote
undoubtedly because as we heard mackel
took her party toward the center and
blurred the boundaries between left and
right how do you see the implications of
that both for the political landscape in
general but also particularly for young
voters
well i think for young voters
i i don't i'm not sure that it will
impact them so much because i i think
that i think that the parties that are
stepping in
are the fdp and the green party which
were both very popular among young
voters they were the strongest so
i think for i think they actually shaped
um shaped this political landscape as
well and i think that's one of the
reasons why i think that there might be
more debates more discussions going on
in parliament that are actually going to
benefit german democracy and lawmaking
so i think you know young people had
such a say in this vote it's actually i
think it's quite a good thing but
obviously the city will have to
it'll be interesting to see what will
happen to the city because it was such a
shaping
staple of german democracy and of course
it's
very important and very much in disarray
right at the moment in fact breaking
down the party's support by age yields
fascinating results while older voters
far and away preferred the mainstream
social democrats and mackel's cdu csu
young ones show a strong preference as
we've heard for the smaller parties the
market-friendly free democrats and the
climate-focused greens
23 of young voters up to the age of 24
voted for the greens
closely followed by the fdp with a 21
share of the vote in this age group
they are followed by the social
democrats with 15
union parties at 10 percent and at the
bottom of the list are the left party
and the afd
the greens have made significant gains
among young voters compared to the 2017
federal election
among voters aged 18 to 24 they had an
increase of 10 in the vote and an 11
increase among voters up to 34 years of
age
for the fdp the picture is similar but
not quite as strong their votes
increased by nine percent among voters
aged 24 years and under and for voters
up to 34 years of age their share
increased by four percent
so regita the attraction of the greens
for young voters seems pretty
self-explanatory one only needs to think
of the fridays for future
movement and in fact we had
young climate activists doing a hunger
strike right before this election trying
to make that point but there's been more
speculation about why young people would
be attracted to a free market party like
the fdp what's your take on that
well part of it i think is that worry
that we're talking about of the
stability that might be gone with angela
merkel
and also part of it that there are some
conservative young people i mean not all
young people are you know left-wing and
they care about the environment there
are some people who are conservative who
worry about their pensions who worry
about their salaries about taxes and all
this and they did not want to vote for
sirius i mean lachet because
he wasn't trustworthy for them for them
he wasn't you know someone who connected
with them on so many levels
i mean take an example that was striking
for me during the election campaign that
when he was asked for example to name
three things on the agenda that he wants
to do when he gets into to the office he
could only name two things and then when
the reporter said well what's the third
well he said what else can we do so for
a lot of people i think that was a
striking moment that the city who
actually have run out of ideas so if i
am a conservative and i want to vote for
you know a center-right party i wouldn't
vote for the city i'd go for the
liberals i think a lot of them thought
that way then you mean a couple of other
explanations i've heard in the last few
days and i haven't seen exact exit polls
on this but certainly there's a lot of
discussion about it i've heard
explanations for the youth vote uh for
the for the fdp ranging from startup
culture to young people tired of
lockdowns wanting their freedom back and
thinking that the free democrats
emphasis on freedom might guarantee that
what do you think i think there's
several reasons for that on one side is
how they communicate where you see how
they are active on social media how they
use instagram how they use tiktak how
they approach young people and of course
freedom is very important for the free
business ftp party they called for
lifting restrictions and to see how
proportionate this corona measures are
especially for school kids and students
who were like the last ones who really
got the freedoms back
and that's the only party who asked for
lifting the restriction without siding
with the credit income movement because
the afd the far right did the same they
said we need our freedoms back but also
siding with anti-vaxxers and people
spreading conspiracy theories so i think
that's where the ftp really
well a lot of young people knew and got
got to know this party and that's why
they also had a very good result with
young voters i just i just want to say
like the afd is also
just
you know has such racist
standpoints and politicians that i think
that is hopefully for a lot of young
people a reason not to vote for them
even if they may agree with like some of
the
some of their points regarding covet
measures nonetheless in the east many
young people did vote for the afd so
let's take a brief diversion because i
very much want to get back to the ftp in
the greens but
talk to us a little bit about the result
in the east also as it pertains to
younger voters please valerie because
what we've seen is a real split in this
election result with the afd in the
single digits in the west and in double
digits up to 25
of the vote in some of the eastern
states actually taking first place where
is this going and what does it mean for
young people well i think that's really
interesting because if you look at the
youth vote and i just looked this up
before the show
six percent of young voters in the west
voted for the afd and 18 in the east and
this is just very interesting because we
thought that the country was
was growing together kind of after the
fall of the wall and everything you know
it's been 30 years so we kind of thought
that the country was growing together
but it seems that there's still just
such a divide within and i think we
really have to explore that i mean i'm
not i'm not completely sure
why this is still such
why
in the east there seems to be such
frustration also among young people
with the federal republic essentially
and i think we really have to look at
that but it's not a new phenomenon the
afd was strong with young voters in the
east
since it's
since its founding in 2013. there seem
also to be some interesting disparities
in terms of education and afd votes but
i suggest we leave it there because our
time is very very limited and i do want
to ask all of you to talk a little bit
about where things go from here so when
you talk about disparities by the way
there are some very significant
disparities between the greens and the
fdp some of them in fact
reflected in our first report where we
heard the slight tensions between
concern about stability as opposed to
the need for dramatic transformation in
connection with climate so
let's talk a little bit about that and
these pre-exploratory talks that the
greens and the fdp are currently
conducting with each other in germany
exploratory talks are normally the
preliminary to proper coalition
negotiations but it's quite unique that
the two smaller parties have decided to
get started on this amongst each other
the two of them together
so
what do you think all of you starting
with regita are there real areas of
commonality here will they find them and
do you think that their key goals will
wind up being very watered down in the
process
well of course there will be some
commonalities or they wouldn't sit with
each other from the beginning
and i think that picture that they
published uh yesterday of the four
leaders when they were sitting together
selfie a very funny selfie yeah i think
that says a lot i mean
they didn't say what happened in those
talks if they agreed on anything but i
think that picture in itself says a lot
that they are willing to come
you know over those obstacles and reach
some kind of an agreement um and
they know i think also that there have
there is a lot of responsibility on them
too as the small two parties because if
they can't agree then there is no
government or there's a minority
government or like there isn't really
much many options all the spd and the
union has to have to get back together
and no one really wants that
how do you see it benjamin
they say they're going in there
not with a lot of red lines but to try
to identify common projects of joint
interest uh do you think they can be
successful at that i think so and they
know what their task is and having these
two king makers so the ftp and the
greens working and when you see what's
going on in the union you know i mean
russia destil
kind of trying to stick to the
chancellery and the spd of course also
waiting i think they know what the two
parties have in common is that they want
to change the status quo especially in a
country that has like a love affair with
the status quo with this conservatives
ideas when you see schulz as you
mentioned you know presenting himself in
a really miraculous way and then you
have these two parties
having new ideas and trying to bring
them into the government and getting
used to the idea that the conservatives
who've been in the chancellery for the
past 16 years could go into a position i
think it's
really really interesting let me ask you
this valerie exit polls
that
on topics that voters viewed as decisive
for how they cast their vote actually
put social welfare issues first before
climate interestingly enough
now is that also true for younger voters
would you say and could concern about
jobs and earnings wind up dampening the
urge for more stringent climate policy
i think that's always a possibility but
if the green parties make if the green
party makes good on their promise to
only
to
um have a lot of social
programs that are supposed to sort of um
cushion the blow maybe of of the client
policies that that have to be put in
place i think there's a good chance that
or there is a chance i mean this is
going to be this transformation is going
to be so devastating for so many reasons
and it's going to be very very hard and
i think politicians have to say that and
they haven't been saying it enough
during this election campaign in my
opinion
so i think that is a great concern and i
do think
that one of the benefits of an of a ampa
coalition um traffic light co-operation
traffic light coalition spd being read
the free democrats yellow and the green
screen of course exactly um is that um i
think people trust the social democrats
a bit more than they trust the green
party to actually implement social
programs for people who are going to
suffer um under under the transformation
that has to happen and under for example
a higher price for for co2 um and stuff
like that so so i do think that um that
there is you know and young people are
impacted by this just as much as older
voters i'd say
of course let me ask uh because we're
just about out of time but let me come
back to our title uh how much change
does germany need how much change do
youth voters truly want and ask both of
you whether you think a traffic light
coalition of the type we're talking
about can really deliver what this
country needs regita no not really
because everybody will have to make
compromises and we will end up with
something in the middle
certainly benjamin if you think about it
we've got an older white man leading
this new traffic light coalition yes it
may include some smaller parties that
haven't been governing before but do you
think it can deliver more change than
the stasis we saw over the last four i
think it can and it should change is
always important
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us and thanks to all of
you for joining in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you